thought it was going to be a sloppy
morning commute and thankfully we've
been spared from that welcome to
september our first day of the new month
meteorologically speaking it's the
beginning of fall but it doesn't feel
too falish out there it feels very soupy
air is very heavy with humidity and
moisture we've got 70s all over the las
vegas valley we have had a little rain
but only trace amounts which really
doesn't count as measurable rainfall so
for the month of august and heading into
september we're still sitting at zero
wow we should be a lot more we should
have a lot more rain in the rain bucket
than what we've got now we've only got
an inch and a third for the year where
we should be close to three inches we're
behind we need more rain for they sure
need rain in northern california that
calder fire is growing to almost 200 000
acres it's within three miles now of the
city of south lake tahoe 3 500
firefighters are trying to battle this
fire and thousands and thousands of
residents now have been evacuated red
flag warnings for gusty dry winds still
in place today up around lake tahoe
western nevada reno washoe counties
they're looking at winds that could be
up 40 45 50 miles an hour
that red flag warning in place until 11
o'clock tonight flash flood watches for
just about all of arizona still up into
utah and eastern clark county southern
clark county has been taking out taken
out of the flash flood watch area we
expect any really heavy rainfall to be
east of the valley today but we've seen
some pretty heavy rainfall even
overnight and it's still continuing
we're seeing some showers on the radar
down in southern clark county this
morning searchlight getting a little
rain calamari as well as
laughlin getting in on some as well as
prim and state line we've had a few
sprinkles a few little lights brief
showers but nothing significant not
going to rule out that we won't get some
showers through the morning hours maybe
even an embedded thunderstorm highs this
afternoon mid 90s with some breaks of
sunshine and more drying from the west
tonight and that will leave us with good
sunshine thursday friday to finish the
week we roll into labor day weekend with
some hotter triple digits and then a
little nudge of monsoon moisture back on
monday it's going to be hot and maybe a
little sticky too got to watch the skies
if you've got those family barbecues
planned and john don't forget we start
the fall watering schedule today too you
have three assigned watering days